bonjour bienvenue dans ces caches
l'émission qui assurent sans vous
rassurer ne croyez pas que c'est un banc
de sardines
c'est un banc de sardines avec des gros
car à l'intérieur les très riches en ont
profité la classe moyenne s'est fait
laminer et va continuer à se faire
laminer et ensuite les pauvres sont
devenues de plus en plus beau c'est pas
l'état qui relancent l'économie ça ne
l'a jamais été
ce qu'on lui demande c'est surtout d'en
faire le moins possible peut pas avoir
confiance en des gens qui font des
bêtises depuis 30 ans c'est juste
ridicule comme comme d'habitude ça
s'appelle botter en touche
c'est une secte l'europe 1 donc il faut
pas il faut pas en sortir cette espèce
de petite mafia européenne non élue qui
rajoute de l'incompétence à
l'incompétence ça fait beaucoup
d'incompétence faut que les guignols
arrête de faire des guignolade qu'est ce
que fait l'état
ils continuent à s'endetter je voulais
dit cent fois ici que de la dette
c'est de l'impôt futur c'est pas la
queue qui remue le chien mais c'est le
chien qui remue la queue ça vous pète à
la figure plus tard tout d'un coup on
s'aperçoit quand on soulève le capot on
s'aperçoit qu'il ya pas de moteur riom
pour qu'aucune de ces prévisions ne se
déroule
ceci n'était pas un nouvel épisode de
walking dead mais pourtant on a parlé de
zombies tout le temps